poor Tom his rich but he's stupid by now
we've all heard that Trump wants to
build a wall on the us-mexico border and
not just any wall a big beautiful
powerful wall like this I'm in Tijuana
along the us-mexico border looking at
some of the anti-trump art that's
popping up here last fall an activist
collective called in decline came here
and painted a mural playing off of
Trump's own words this is what it looked
like freshly painted but just hours
before our visit Mexican activists to
face the mural with green spray paint
Rafael lives across the street and saw
it all go down well screaming and
telling bad words to a guy to trump like
he was here as if Trump was here they
were yelling at him rather than all
kinds of stone mean crazy I was afraid
of my Trump wants to build a wall on the
us-mexico border and he says Mexico is
gonna pay for it what do you think I
don't know a Mexico Spain I'm not paying
across town artists Medeiros Joe and his
family struck a more positive tone with
their mural called
we are all migrants including Trump I
put the schedule plan because his mother
is from Scotland so he's a immigrant I
guess
and there's the Syrian girl and the CD
I'm black in the back because I was
thinking on the refugees in Syria and
all the problem that they have over
there it's the same here that's why
modei included a Mexican Salvadorian and
Chinese woman on the mural as well
what are the butterflies represent the
representing immigration they have to
fly a lot of Commerce to to look for
their destiny
and they don't have borders did herb
work this mural isn't very negative at
all even though Donald Trump has said
some very negative things about
immigrants and about Mexicans why isn't
it negative I'm just trying to to chose
that we all can be together like here in
the in the wall we're all together and
nothing happens and we all different
yeah but I'm we're all humans and we can
work together